diplomatie noter que vladimir poutine a
reçu hier le pot ministre israélien
naftali bennet pas de détails sur ce que
se sont dit les deux hommes naftali
bennet doit s'entretenir avec volodymyr
zelensky et le chancelier allemand olaf
schulze pour en parler stéphane hamard
nous appelle de jérusalem bonjour
stéphane est ce que on peut dire qu'il
existe une médiation une tentative de
médiation israélienne dans cette crise
où il absolument d'abord ce n'est pas la
première fois
qu'il ya des contacts entre poutine et
bennett est également d'ailleurs entre
poutine et à l'aise puisque israël se
veut un petit peu l'intermédiaire en
sursis bp pourquoi d'abord et surtout
par ci une très forte diaspora russe
sourceone ici en israël à la fois des
juifs originaires d'ukraine et des juifs
originaires de russie qui vivent ici
d'un million de personnes plus de 20% de
la population est originaire d'ex union
soviétique il ya donc de très nombreux
liens mais aussi parce que ces dernières
années et bien on a assisté à la
rapprochement entre vladimir poutine et
les israéliens et entre eux staelens
quitter les six très bien en contre que
l'ukraine et israël et donc israël
compte à exploiter ses contacts ses
contacts parfois par le diplomate
pour aboutir à une mutation israël qui
est aussi on peut le rappeler quelque
peu coincé stéphane entre le
traditionnels alliés américains et sept
amis russes
absolument ça a été très très difficile
pour y serait de se positionner et
d'ailleurs ça l'est toujours parce
qu'effectivement il serait l'ami du
temps a condamné l'invasion
de vladimir poutine de l'ukraine parce
qu' il serait ne voulait pas compris les
marasmes entendre entre la syrie et
israël toutes les actions israéliennes
en syrie sont coordonnés avec la russie
mais effectivement vous disiez le
véritable allié d'israël l'allié
historique et principal ce sont les
états unis il ya donc eu beaucoup de
pression notamment à l'onu pour qui ce
règne condamne l' invasion de l'ukraine
par la russie et israël cherche pour ce
chemin étroit entre ses intérêts pour ne
pas compromettre évidemment sur
l'alliance essentiel avec lui mais en
même temps pour ne pas arriver à une
situation de confrontation avec la route
qui qui est également un acteur très
important ici au proche orient merci
stéphane hamard à jérusalem notez aussi
que de nouvelles man